all right so congrats on your new baby
on the way
um that's coming soon to a home near you
yeah
are you excited it's the treat that i've
been able to get within all of this you
know
yeah yeah so i'm really looking forward
to uh the arrival of my
my little bean oh my god they smell so
good and i look my favorite part is the
skin on skin
yeah when oh my god it's my favorite so
so here's skin on skin talking skin on
skin you know i have used
my girl she's actually introduced this
idea she's like you know what
you have to really connect with the baby
so i'm going to buy you like
the male like feeding thing i'm like i'm
not wearing that
oh my god like i'm not going to wear it
she wants me to wear the
i'm not wearing the boots man i mean i
thought about it i
oh my gosh that's amazing i really want
pictures
um oh so wait so how did you break the
news to your sons about a new one
oh man just you know just talking about
the reality of growing up and you know
they're now 11 and 12 sixth and seventh
grade
yeah now they're big boys that's junior
high yeah
more than enough time to have prepared
for it but you know babies are gifts
from god
and being able to kind of broaden our
soul circle man and just
just celebrate this moment and know that
they're big brothers
you know i know oh my gosh i'm just so
jealous of the little baby look
um so did your sons get into tick-tock
at all
did they yeah they do do you get into it
uh you know what surprisingly i have to
give my kids credit
for modernizing me they actually tend to
call me a boomer
but um uh so they've come up with a few
challenges right so there's the flip to
switch um
challenge we did that one yes uh and it
was pretty fun we did that at my mom's
house right there check that out yes
funny right there check it i love
look at look we take a picture
and it's a picture when we were younger
we all were younger
and uh and we did it but yeah my my uh
my son naveed
he's actually uh really really hooked on
it
yeah yeah he's he's beyond hooked every
second of the day is like tick tock tick
tock tick tock yeah i know
it's a little much but now it's funny
because you know we've always told our
kids like get off the computer like this
whole time and then covet hits and
you're like it's fine
it looks like mommy needs a minute then
you're doing school it's like so much
screen time